- [Voiceover] So let's see
if we can find the limit
as X approaches negative
one of six X squared
plus five X minus one.
Now the first thing that
might jump out at you
is this right over here,
this expression could be used
to define the graph of a parabola.
And when you think about
this, I'm not doing
a rigorous proof here, parabola would look
something like this and this would be an
upward opening parabola,
look something like this.
It is a, this graph,
visually, is continuous,
you don't see any jumps or gaps in it.
And in general,
a quadratic like this
is going to be defined for all values of X
for all real numbers, and
it's going to be continuous,
oh, for all real numbers.
And so if something is
continuous for all real numbers,
well then the limit as X
approaches some real number
is going to be the same
thing, it's just a value
within the expression at that real number.
So what am I saying, I'm just
gonna say it another way,
we know that some function is continuous,
is continuous at some
X value, at X equals A
if and only if, I'll
write that as iff, or iff,
if and only if the limit
as X approaches A of F of X
is equal to F of,
is equal to F of A.
So I didn't do a rigorous proof here,
but just, it's conceptually not a big jump
to say, okay, well this
is, this is just a standard
quadratic right over here,
it's defined for all real numbers,
and in fact it's continuous
for all real numbers.
And so we know that this expression,
it could define a continuous function,
so that means that the
limit as X approaches A
for this expression is just the same thing
as evaluating this expression at A.
And in this case, our A is negative one.
So all I have to to is
evaluate this at negative one.
This is going to be six
times negative one squared
plus five times negative one minus one.
So that's just one, this is negative five,
so it's six minus five minus one,
which is equal to
zero.
And we are done.